hey guys this is another video request
and some of you asked me hey danielle
how do i get wider teeth
fast at home well let's jump right into
the video
and i'll tell you
[Music]
now just very quick if it's your first
time here on my channel i'm daniel and
welcome to dln model
lifestyle on this channel i talk about
fitness grooming style and
life itself so if you haven't subscribed
yet please consider it and also click
that notification bell
so you won't miss any of the next videos
now let's look at the first thing you
need to do to get
wider teeth
the first thing you got to do is to stay
away from foods that make your teeth
yellow in the first place
prevention is always better than
treatment afterwards
so you got to stay away from food like
tomatoes
curry pasta and berries and also drinks
like coffee
tea red wine and other dark drinks or
foods they contain pigment producing
substances
that can make your teeth yellow now i
don't mean you have to stay away from it
completely
because i love my coffee and i love
certain foods and i'm still going to eat
it but you need some balance
so don't go overboard and then very
importantly rinse your mouth out with
water
after you're done eating or drinking and
also remember
to brush your teeth to clean it and to
get rid of all the plaque buildup
now if you don't brush your teeth
regularly of course you're going to get
stains it's going to look yellow and
that's
not what you want now other things that
causes yellow teeth
are genetics sugar and smoking or
chewing tobacco
so here's another reason why you should
stop smoking
apart from cancer money and bad odors
alright let's move on to the next one
whitening toothpaste now come on down
does it really work
well yes not in a big drastic way but it
does work
i use it all the time and my teeth stays
white and
yeah shiny but you gotta use it the
right
way most people just brush their teeth
quickly spit it out and that
and just okay that's it that's done do
you actually know how long
you gotta brush your teeth i know it's
not 10 seconds 20 seconds 30 seconds
it's actually
two minutes and then after i've brushed
my teeth for two minutes what i do then
is i push the whitening toothpaste to
the front of my mouth and i keep it
there
to the front of my teeth for 30 seconds
to one minute
before i spit it out and it works
[Music]
next one is baking soda what you want to
do is you want to make a paste kind of
thing you want to
take the baking soda add some water and
then add whitening toothpaste to it
it will not only help with the bacteria
in your mouth
but it's also going to help you with the
stains on your teeth
and it's so easy to try it out because
you can buy it everywhere you can buy it
online you can buy it at the store
try it out it works
[Music]
hydrogen peroxide now most of you
probably already know that this is a
natural bleaching
agent right but a lot of people also use
it to disinfect
wounds because it kills bacteria
but you can also use it to whiten your
teeth
try it out it works you can actually mix
it with baking soda as well
activated charcoal now there's not
as much evidence for this as there is
for baking soda
and hydrogen peroxide but thousands of
people say that
it works but then also a lot of other
people thousands of people say it
doesn't work
so what is this what is activated
charcoal
well it's basically this black powder
made from coal
bone char peat coconut shells petroleum
coke
olive pits or sawdust it helps to pull
the toxins
from your mouth and also supposedly
whitens your teeth
i don't know i'm just being honest i
haven't seen any
difference but i'll add some links for
in the video description so you can do
your own
research
[Music]
apple cider vinegar some people say that
this works great
i haven't tested it myself and i won't
because
it can cause tooth decay and weakens the
enamel
of your teeth so i'm not gonna test it i
wouldn't
actually recommend it but it also
supposedly
whitens your teeth let's go to the next
one
at home teeth whitening kits some
do not work that well but some do look
for the professional ones
i use it myself and it works for me now
of course they cannot give you that
super white teeth that a dentist can
but it will give you that white smile
that you want
but please don't go for those cheap
quick fixes
don't go for those ones go for the
professional teeth whitening kits
they contain bleach which is a peroxide
that will whiten
your teeth i'll add some good options
for you in the video description down
below
that you can check out
and then finally the best thing go and
see
your dentist because they can do a
professional cleaning for you and also
whiten
your teeth now before i go let me leave
you with this
take care of your teeth because your
smile
is the best thing that you can wear i'll
see you guys in the next video
cheers